i did an indian casino recently oh yeah
my last gig i just did it's funny
because you know no it's an indian
casino is that like a dry situation
where you don't it was so i bring these
little tito bottles of
vodka like little airplane ones maybe
one or two in the socks just to keep the
party going
so i fly you know to this casino what a
[ __ ] or whatever fine good for me yeah
i got to make those honda accord
payments somehow you know absolutely
honda cord's a nice car pay for the
serious yeah so i get i get land and i
gotta drive an hour
and then the lady's like a tough sort of
older
woman like been around the block been
there forever
she goes ah another gig for you huh i go
yep yep
so we we get there
and then she goes there's no dressing
room this is your rv in the parking lot
i go god it's like some crummy rv it's
102 for real so it's sizzling i get in
there in the wispy wallet i'm getting
sunburned through the wall i'm like god
damn this can't be happening and then
she goes knock knock meanwhile my driver
uh ideally would be in the car right but
she comes in and goes hey
probably not supposed to come in here i
just want to give you a heads up it's a
dry casino
like i'm [ __ ] foster brooks how old
is this woman uh
she's about
70. and she's your driver yeah so i go
oh yeah i go i hurt i go you know what i
had a hunch so i slipped in me tito's in
my socks i got two and she was not gonna
do it i go well you know i weigh 140 i
think i'll be right
and then i go i'll just have some at
dinner and she goes dry restaurant
i go [ __ ]
actually got her
finger on the pulse of the booze in this
town
so i go oh [ __ ] really i should be all
right so i go i come out i got a little
bit of a buzz but i come out she knocks
again how you feeling party boy i go
you guys you want me to make a run for
you there's a liquor store right by here
and i go i don't know she goes i'll make
her run i don't know if i need drink
shoes you need to drink you want it yeah
you like it you love it you want some
more tito's
so i go uh all right so she goes i'll do
a covert run i go i don't think anyone
gives a [ __ ] you know so she goes oh no
no i'll go i'll go i go okay jason
bourne so she sneaks off she comes back
in and she goes okay i got some stuff
for the talent and then she knocks in i
got it i got it i go all right drug
dealer so then she goes here's your abba
zaba she had to water it down a bit yeah
yeah here's here's a comb a yo-yo and
then she goes reaches in her bra here's
your tito out of her bra oh one t to the
other one she's like yank and i go oh
that's me nip all right here's your
other tito puts it down and then uh i go
oh gross thanks
and then she goes uh hey slug him i go
no no no
she goes get your buzz get out there and
bring the funny
and i go who is this i don't know and i
go i got it from here i got it from here
so anyway i go to the show crush kill
whatever other people's words standing o
but anyway the only embarrassing thing i
ordered a jet to get me home because it
was pretty far away i'm working on the
show i go i want to come home late i get
a crowbar on the wall and i go let's get
a jet fine so me and bobby my my opener
guy we look at you we get in the back of
the sprinter and i'm like conked out you
know because it's show and buzz is
fading away now i'm more into cranky
mode
and then she goes that's usually the how
it goes the trajectory so then she goes
we're i go as fast as you can just got
to get to the airport yeah yeah and then
two months later
can i ask a favor
i don't know if we're at the favor level
at this relationship i go what is yours
this could get me fired
oh no she goes my granddaughter i'm a
grandma shocker yeah uh i she's 11.
loves joe dirt says all the quotes does
all the i go you want me to call her she
goes no can we pop over there for a
second oh
she's just a couple clicks off the
freeway i go clicks
vietnam how about that military sounds
far she goes nah it's just a little
zigzag then a beep bop boop and then
we're right there i go uh
and i never do this cause i'm [ __ ]
great guy syndrome but i go i i can't i
go we gotta get there and they gotta
take off at certain times she was yeah
yeah like she's already [ __ ] grousing
yeah and so like all right and then i
start to zonk out again two seconds
later
he's right here hold on
you're on i'm like [ __ ] and it's a face
time i go jesus oh my god so i'm
crawling to the front and she's like
sticking it through that little window
swerving
here that's him look so i go oh hi i
crawl up hi you know she's like hi i'm
like hey
you watch the movie you know whatever i
say and then i see the chick look at me
like she's like
amp up the funny you're bombing
i'm bombing i'm doing my and she goes
give her some stuff from the movie i'm
like hey dang you know what's crapping
and kids like couldn't give a [ __ ] and
then and then she takes the phone away
from me she goes he's tired he's tired
i'll call you later oh my god you bombed
and get the worst review from grandma
[ __ ] that kid she was like cindy brady
freezing up on me she didn't help me at
all